hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast how to deploy a portable
lab for the surveillance of emerging
infectious diseases presented by Josh
quick a research fellow at university of
birmingham i'm susie valdez of lab
routes and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
Oxford nanopore technologies Oxford
nanopore technologies aims to disrupt
the paradigm of biological analysis
their technologies and commercial model
has already opened the DNA analysis to
researchers who previously had no direct
access to sequencing technologies
bringing them up to perform analysis in
their own labs or in their field or in
real time before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on the green
Q&A button located at the lower left of
the presentation window and type that
question into the box that appears in
the screen well answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also notice that you will
be viewing this presentation in a slide
window to enlarge that slide window
click on the screen icon located at the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of the presentation window or use
that Q&A button and let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
educational credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow that process for obtaining your
credits without further ado please join
me in welcoming Josh quick I will now
turn the presentation over to him
welcome sir
thank you very much
introduction Susie so thank you for that
introduction my name is Josh quick and
I'm a researcher at the University of
Birmingham and we are a genomics
research group we try to find new
innovative ways and applications but for
genomics or DNA sequencing technologies
of which Oxford nanopore prepare have
developed such a technology and I have
traveled to various outbreaks around the
world taking with me a mobile lab but
with at its heart an Oxford nanopore
portable DNA sequencer and we have been
able to use that technology to tackle
and control ongoing outbreaks in this
particular talk I'm going to be talking
about two viral epidemics which you will
definitely have heard of the first is
the boner outbreak in West Africa and
the second one is the Zika outbreak in
in South America and we used portable
genomics and surveillance we call it
which means you which I'm using to refer
to when you know that something is there
and you want to keep an eye on it rather
than trying to constantly new and and we
and what we did there in those countries
so the Oxford nanopore min iron
technology is very interesting because
it's allowed among other things the
first truly portable genome sequencing
to be performed and it's really opened
up this whole new area of field
sequencing so previous generations of
instruments were quite large around the
size of the photocopier something like
that or maybe a laser printer but they
weren't very portable whereas the
whereas the min ion because of its you
know because of its technology it
doesn't it doesn't have any moving parts
it means that it can actually connect to
a laptop computer and it's only really
the size of the USB stick
so give you some examples of some mobile
sequencing so this is us and that's a
brewery in Austin Texas majestic in
brewery doing some analysis on some
spontaneous fermentation beers and we
are actually able to take everything
down there this is sort of hobby of ours
really it's more of a site that's more
of a sort of public engagement activity
and we like to look at fermentation and
what are the Mike and what of them like
what's the microbiology involved in
fermentation and you know do it right
there and there in the field this is an
example from Aberystwyth Godwin Edwards
Aberystwyth University where he's
actually doing DNA sequencing in the in
the Arctic at the 78th parallel and he's
actually collecting samples doing the
analysis in a mobile lab and then
actually making a decision about what to
do next maybe move the sampling location
altogether or something like that so so
that's that's an example of where you
can improve the efficiency of working in
these types of environments this is a
photo from a researcher called Aaron
Aaron Pomerance he was using the minion
to identify species of snakes in the
Ecuadorian jungle and you can see all
the equipment Bay is there this is an
underwater laboratory called the
Aquarius where they eat where they test
out they test our technology in austere
environments where there's you know this
is 25 meters under the sea and this one
you may have heard of this one in the
news this is aboard the ISS and this is
a gastric cake Hubbins astronaut cake
oven he's he's sorry Kate Rubin's who's
there been doing testing out the the use
of the minion in in space or near space
orbit so that's an example of a sort of
more future looking project and into
whether or not the minion could be used
on long
missions or you know manned missions to
Mars and whether or not the min I could
be used to detect and diagnose infection
for treating illness on those long
journeys so now let's talk about my my
experiences this is a this is my mobile
lab that I took to West Africa in April
2015 and this is my this is my trolley
at Heathrow Airport
that's aboard a plane - the captain of
Guinea in West Africa Conakry so how did
we get to this point and and what do we
have to do - to put this this this
equipment together what so I'm going to
go through some of the key things so
I've already mentioned me the reason
that we chose the minion is because it's
a very small instrument compared to the
previous generations of instruments it's
a very lightweight and requires sort of
fewer support equipment so it doesn't
require mains power things like that
which makes it very good for a you know
an environment where there might be
frequent power cuts it's also relatively
cheap you know the actual consume the
flow cell is actually a disposable
consumable which are now allows us to to
analyze these samples relatively cost
efficiently so that's going to be the
first thing that you pack in your in
your mobile lab and so the the device
itself this is the product it's a it's a
it's a and a small hinged device whether
with the main the main erm the main
stuff going on in this in this
disposable flow cell which I which is a
single useful a cell so this is the top
are here you are you actually the way
that it works is you connect this to
your computer you prepare what we call a
DNA library and then you drop your
library onto the area here which is
which is where
the tiny nano pores are which is what
read off the sequence of the DNA that
you put onto the fillet cell now going
style in little bit more detail in next
slide so Nana pores are a biological
proteins and they they you know it's
ubiquitous in nature the this this
particular protein comes from is a
membrane protein we're liberating from
ecoli and and unpause insert into
membranes and in this case it's an
insulating membrane which means that the
only so that if a voltage is applied to
it then ions have to flow through the
middle of the pore so you can see in
this diagram here those they small those
small dots represent represent ions
flowing through the pore which is any
way they can get through and that
creates a if you measure if you measure
the current across the membrane that
means you can you create the signal like
this and the actual DNA strand within
the pore is causing a blocking of that
ion flow which is giving a
characteristic change in the current
level which can be measured and that DNA
will travel through poor which is ripped
and it's convinced the speed of which is
controlled by this protein here which is
a recall of the motor protein which
basically slows down the DNA in order to
enough that it can be read and so that's
that's that's slowing down the and
controlling the speed of the of the DNA
to having through the pore and then it's
being read out as a current level and
then it's being read off the instrument
onto the laptop computer where it's
where it's going to be converted into
base calls or bases which is obviously
the the the the alphabet of DNA is made
up and here's another view showing the
same thing but the the actual sequence
that you that you're going through this
that's within the bounds of boys more
than one base at any one time so you can
see in this diagram each bond colored
bar represents a base there's the
poorest is long enough such that there's
multiple bases within the poor which
means that when you actually when you
actually read off a current you're
actually reading off a word that the is
actually a DNA word because it contains
more signal which is coming from other
bases as well and I've represented that
here by using this it's a pretend
sequence here if you imagine the this
this sequence going through the pore and
if you just think about the the base the
see base your school your first
observing it at the last position and as
it slices through the all that you'll
then observe it five times in this case
whether we're the we're assuming that
the word length is five bases so it's a
very very tiny measurement that you're
making it's a very small single molecule
measurement that you're making but the
but because you get them because you get
multiple opportunities to observe the
base you can you can use that to combine
me you know these small bits of signal
into what is actually remarkably
accurate DNA sequencing so each the the
actual DNA the actual sequencer is is
reading or the the chip underneath
underneath the flow cell is called the
ayzik and it's a reading reading off
what we call these samples so raw
samples so it's actually sampling the
current at six thousand per say six
thousand times a second and each of
these dots on this plot represents an
individual sample and you can see the
you account for some variation in the in
samples but the red lines represent what
we call events and those are those are
represent one Kaymer
being
one camera in the poor they came up
sorry one word but in the core so he has
their base as the as the sequence
progresses by one base you can see that
you end up with these these signal
levels and this can be converted by
using a base caller which means which
means is a general term which means
calling from the from the data that he
recorded the actual DNA sequence and in
this case we use a base caller that's a
piece of software called albacore and it
takes these raw samples and it uses a
machine learning algorithm to has been
trained unknown sequence to determine
what the actual sequence in of that read
actually is and once we have base calls
we call them reads and that means a DNA
read represents the sequence of one
molecule and that can be used for doing
downstream analysis so the the the min
iron was first launched in May 2014 so
it's the newest DNA sequencing
technology Sony been out less than three
years and and it's a been characterized
by a very rapid that progression in the
in the technology which is I think
fairly common of any sort of
groundbreaking new technology but
there's very there's been a very rapid
improvement from the from the first days
that we we got our hands on this
instrument so I just summarize some of
the new some of the developments over
the months one of the big ones that was
the move to a new pour which I mentioned
before is a it said poured the right
from he coli bacterium and it's been and
it's and it replaced an earlier version
of the port and it was found that it
improved the the base calling an
accuracy
the ability to accurately read off the
correct sequence of the of the DNA
strand that's passing through the pore
so another unique feature of nanopore
sequencing is that it's a it reads whole
molecules which means instead of instead
of reading shorts defined lengths of DNA
which is which is how which is how
creeps how many previous technologies
would have worked it can read whole long
fragments of DNA and really it depends
it really didn't really read anything
that you can manage to get into the
actual device so this is a an example of
the amount of data which we're talking
about here
so these are some runs that we we
performed when we we we actually
sequence the human genome as a side
project on mid-iron
and these numbers are the amount of
bases that you can get from one place oh
so in in the best-case scenario we were
getting four times ten to the nine bases
which is for Giga bases which is
approximately one times the human genome
if you were to read the human genome
once slightly more than once it's also
equivalent to about a thousand thousand
times reading the typical bacterial
genome and these are examples of the of
the read lengths which you can achieve
so for a typical for a typical human run
this shown here the four different types
of libraries we were able to generate
reads anywhere from about 10,000 bases
anywhere up to about 900 thousand bases
so is it's a it's a unique in its
ability to read extremely long pieces of
DNA
so what else are you going to include in
your in your do we need to include in
our mobile lab well we devised certainly
for for I'm going to talk about how how
we sequence the bowler first of all we
that we decided that the simplest way to
try and sequence the bowler would be to
use a technology an all technology
called PCR the polymerase chain reaction
and what that allows you to do so this
is the equipment that we that we took
with us obviously there was some some
some lab where in the top picture but
there was also some cold chain reagents
so most molecular biology reagents
enzymes things like that they require
being kept chilled or frozen to extend
their life so we you know this is this
is not really you know the ideal
situation but it means carrying the
reagents on cold packs to keep them cold
so we use these polystyrene boxes which
are insulating and unpack them with cold
packs to keep them as cold as possible
when we're traveling but once we once we
had it will set up the actual equipment
that we needed to do this a bolus
sequencing was only that much stuff
saying not great deal amout of stuff can
click on two tables and the equivalent
setup for a conventional DNA sequencer
fire and by conventional I mean I've
been stopped instrument which you know
might be the size of the laser printer
required this amount of equipment from
from another group they're also
sequencing and been helping the seeker
do surveillance sequencing in in Sierra
Leone instead of Guinea so PCR you
probably will have heard of the
polymerase chain reaction it's basically
a technique where you start off with a
small number of templates and using
small all of the nucleotide primers you
generate billions of copies of that
template that you're interested in and
it's it's it's notable that it's quite a
robust technology but it's also very
sensitive in theory a single template is
enough to to to generate you know
billions or billions or trillions of
copies because the because the reaction
is exponential varied for every for
every - for every molecule you get two
more so you get an exponential number of
copies so it's very good it's got very
good sensitivity and that's one of the
reasons that we we chose it for for this
project so the way that we decided to do
it was to design primers which would
cover the entire bowl of genome so a
bowler is a small RNA virus which means
it uses RNA as its as this including its
its genome it contains only seven genes
which are which are represented by the
blue arrows and it's only about 18
thousand bases long so what we decided
to do given its small size was to design
lots of 500 base pair amplicons we call
them which is which is products
generated by PCR or amplification that
500 base pair products which go across
the genome and are next to each other or
slightly overlapping such that you can
we call it tiling our way along the
genome using lots of using lots of short
products the one we got there we then
realized that we could actually miss out
every other primer and generate thousand
base pairings and then every unit every
every fourth and January 2000
base pair amplicons and could tile
across the genome in in every in 2000
based their products and any years and
eleven reactions so some of the early
data that we that we generated in the UK
and in guinea show that we were able to
sequence the entire bola genome using
these these overlapping amplicons that I
described then left to right is the is
the genome the coordinates in the genome
say 0 to 18,000 and and then there why
but in why is this the number of reads
that are aligned to that position of the
genome said we call that the death so
using these 11 reactions we were able to
cover 98.4% of the Ebola genome a high
depth which was which meant that we were
able to recover
you know 98% of all the bases in that
genome for analysis so what we say
there's a too quickly
say how you how you could tell you then
go from from a PCR product to to the
sequencer you actually start off with so
there's two types two main types of
libraries that you can do for the for
the midline if you have amplicons you
want this type of library because you've
already got double-stranded amplicons
and really what you want to do is just
stick on these adapters on to the end so
starting at the step where the arrow is
and and then create these products which
of which can then be loaded onto the
sequencer which contain the motor on the
on the adapter the motor I talked about
earlier when I was describing the sepia
these the flow cell the motor protein
sits on the end of the adapter which is
located on to the amplicons which mean
that when you put them into the flow
cell they are able to interact with the
poor and initiate that sequencing lead
there's another type of library
preparation method which we call the
rapid method and that uses an enzyme
called a transpose which can be primed
with adapters which means that you can
enzymatically then cut into a double
stranded piece of DNA and insert the
adapters and this is very useful for
sequencing genomic DNA but for PCR
products you want you don't want to cut
into the middle of your product you want
to sequence the whole thing from start
from from from end to end so we use the
ligation chemistry on the left so final
the final piece of the puzzle is the
data analysis that we need to be able to
do so when I was in we generated this
the this this data for for for these
Ebola samples that we that we had and we
needed to be able to - then - to
actually do the analysis and that
involved doing the base calling which I
talked about earlier but also comparing
to other genomes and generating a
phylogenetic tree so we needed to be
able to to upload this data because at
the time there was no there was no such
thing as a base corner that could run on
your laptop that you had with you so we
needed to be able to use what was what
was the only base corner available back
in back in this at this time of 2015 was
a cloud-based caller called metric or so
we needed an internet connection to be
able to upload the data to their cloud
base caller so initially I I took the
laptop back to the hotel I was staying
at which is pitted pitch in the top left
and I uploaded the data using the
hotel's Wireless now which was probably
one of the faster connections in the
city so that was a satellite connection
we also investigated how how much it
helped how expensive it be to have our
own satellite connection the answer is
very expensive and then we eventually
settled on using just the typical 3G
hotspots like the ones like the ones
shown here and this one was given to me
about a lot of Health Organization who
organized the trips to Guinea and I
actually went around bought some SIM
cards off of people in the street and
top-up cards and tested the different
speeds and we eventually found this this
network where we could get a fast enough
upload speed such that we could upload
the data from one one a boiler genome
you know
reasonable time frame with about an hour
so that was what we we did going forward
so as I said the blackened back in 2015
the only available the only available
bass caller was a bass caller that ran
in the cloud called metric or now
there's a there's there's there's many
more options available to us including
local based calling on the laptop your
laptop itself and another plate another
local based caller called albacore see
we things have moved on since since we
did this and making this type of thing
easier so in an app or as I mentioned
earlier because it's a single single
molecule it's measuring the current from
a single poor single DNA strand reading
for the poor here's a what we call a
noise noisy or aeroplane technology and
that's that base that that terminology
basically comes from the the distinction
between amplifying a single molecule to
create clonal copies of it before you
sequence it which gives you amplifying
the signal or sequencing just a single
copy where you're more likely to make
errors in the read in the sequencing
because you have much lower
signal-to-noise so we are we in
collaboration with a guy called Jared
Simpson who's at the Ontario Institute
for cancer research that develops them
some tools for doing read correction and
we were able to apply this to to Ebola
to be able to call be the snips or the
single nucleotide polymorphisms the
single changes in the genome which we
use to do this type of analysis and very
accurately and we actually benchmark
that against the gold standard and found
any was there was able to call all of
the variants that we then we know we had
in the genome so that was that was
possible by going by taking the the
baseball sequence
and then then combining that with the
original mana poor emission data say the
raw data say including both the base
calls and the raw data - to increase the
accuracy of the of the bait of the
variant calls so this is a this is this
is an analogous application but for
example sequencing a bacterial genome
using this algorithm the the the
accuracy that you can get from using
using the raw data as well is 99.9 6
about 300 times coverage and this is
actually an alignment of Ebola
sequencing reads whereby you can see the
the single sort of sporadic chain
differences in the in the sequences
which are actually errors of sequencing
errors which are labelled on there and
then a genuine biological change between
the sample that we've sequenced and the
reference genome which is actually a
real snip and you can see it's quite
easy to in this case quite easy to you
see that that's a real snip because it's
supported by the majority of reads but
in certain circumstances it's very
important to use the raw the raw data to
improve the accuracy of these calls so
we had we came up with this big long
pipeline bioinformatics pipeline which
has now been which is now has now been
actually doc arised and we can we can
run this on a laptop right there in the
field so things have really moved on a
lot since then but you know it's
important to to design your analysis
because it's you know properly because
minnow and aether is very different from
other other types of data so it's
necessarily complicated in this case so
the we we also had us had a question
research question when we were doing
this which was basically can we can we
set up this lab and can we generate
genome data in the field in a useful
time frame and I think that that was
certainly proved to be very successful
more successful than me maybe we even
expected and this was going this isn't
this is this this is an image of a
funeral going on during the Ebola
outbreak is an incredibly tragic
outbreak for more than 10,000 deaths so
the but one of the main drivers of the
of the epidemic was unsafe burials and
in this case you can see the protective
equipment is being used to create a safe
to be quick to safely bury this victim
but but as I said one of the main
drivers of the app to epidemic was was
on safe burials and the WH own who
produced pro doing on ongoing epidemics
they produce what's known as a situation
report and this is an excerpt from the
situation report in October 2015 where
they say that however he is not a known
contact with previous case and genomic
analysis suggests he was not infected
with the strain of Ebola virus
responsible in the most recent cases in
Conakry in Florida and for Acharya and
this is the first time the genomic
analysis had ever been included in in a
situation report and this was data that
we had provided to the to the to the
central to the to the response control
in the previous week and so it was so
that was very gratifying that we were
able to do that so this is the
this is the hospital the senti the main
hospital in Conakry in the capital city
of Guinea where we had the lab set up
and this is me on the left with dr.
massima and miles Carol setting up the
first bolus sequencing run in Guinea and
actually probably anywhere he and the
first data that we got off the
instrument we were able to we were able
to recover you know hundreds of X
coverage of the of the ability known
within as little as 30 minutes after
starting the run so this is a very this
is a very rapid assay once you've
actually done all the lab work up front
the sequencing component there is very
quick indeed and the initial batch of
genomes that we generated I think it's
14 showed that the phylogenetic analysis
of age do you know and showed that they
fell into two distinct clades and this
actually wasn't wasn't known at the time
because there was such a lag period
between between what was going on in the
field and what was actually known about
due to the fact that if you don't have a
mobile lab the only way that you can you
can get to nearly data for these samples
is by is by collecting them all up
packaging them and shipping them out
with us with a special courier which is
happy to handle potentially hazardous
RNA and then send them to a lab which is
equipped to handle them and do the daily
genome sequencing there that whole
process has got a lot of cost there a
lot of time as they said a little bit
whereas if you can do this in the field
you can you can avoid all of those and
bureaucratic hurdles and the time taken
which is which means that you can get
the data in and look you know you know
in a much quicker timeframe and you
might actually be able to do something
about it
so by the time the we gots the end of
this project the lab Ben had been
upgraded to its own Porter cabin these
are the some of the people that start
the the lab did the lab work including
Joseph Bohr a local Guinean scientist
who were trained and you can see him
working away making libraries for the
minion she had a PCR area a sequencing
area and that's the DNA library being
loaded into the flow cell and just to
show how just to illustrate how remote
the actual sequencing was you can see
this picture from Loren Caleigh who
worked he was working in the lab has
taken directly out of the window looking
into dense jungle so you can see that
this was this was genuinely right in the
field and and it was enabled by the 3G
connection to upload the data which I
mentioned earlier so look at these are
these are some overall stats of the of
the of the number of cases in Guinea
from the date that we arrived in country
to to the to the final KC outbreak so we
arrived in March 2015 when there was 265
cases of which we sequence 13 of them
and this was the this was near the end
of yet near the end of the outbreak and
the numbers of favorable cases were
dropping but during that time the
numbers that we actually sequenced
increased and - as we as we got the lab
more established - to a period of time
in June or July where we were pretty
much sequencing all the cases that we
wanted to be the ones that we didn't do
were really cases where there was it
wasn't necessary to sequence all the
isolates for example in family groups
and things like that
and the goth and the graph on the bottom
right shows the time between when the
the sample was first collected so that's
basically when the blood was drawn and
the date in which the sequencing data
was available and as you can see here
for a number of these samples that was
only one or two days after the sample
was collected and that just goes to show
how how powerful mobile labs can be when
you when you consider that the
alternative would be that it would be
sent back to a lab with conventional
sequencing instrument in that it might
take months before you actually have the
data so that's the that really shows you
that the the power of a mobile lab can
generate data quickly and it can
generate in a time frame where you can
actually do still do something about it
so the the phylogenetic analysis which
is effectively a tree shirt illustrating
the the the evolution of the virus over
time the the two boxes which the two the
two boxes there the dotted boxes
illustrate the two two clades that I
talked about earlier the two lineages
which were circulating in the country
and then these are zoomed in versions of
that showing the showing the evolution
of those two two lineages over time and
the color of the of the of the doc tells
you which part the country which
Prefecture that sample came from so you
can see that the the virus was was
moving from one Prefecture to the next
to the next to the next and that's
that's driven by movement of people
infectious infected people that are
transmitting the virus from one
geographic location to the next and the
way that you can reconstruct this tree
is the as the virus amplify
it's an errors are introduced into the
genome and those errors if it's
transmitted persist which means that you
see a change in the genome which wasn't
present in the previous Islip so if you
compare the genomes using these types of
these types of methods phylogenetic
methods you can create a tree which
shows how each sample links to previous
known samples and that can be very
useful information if you are tackling
an outbreak because you're able to see
across big geographic regions or even
countries which isalus are related to
which isolates and that might not be so
obvious if you're dealing with this on
the ground with a sub going narrow focus
then you people are quite mobile and
they're able to move the virus across
large distances especially if they're
using you know air travel so this kind
of analysis is is very important for
being able to see to see how cases
relate to each other and that's and that
was that was very useful information for
me for their people on the ground so the
this plot here is an example of how the
how the genome data the tree and that in
the top left compares to a more
conventional epidemiological picture
that you but you might you might draw up
if you were doing this or research by
doing into these and talking to people
and doing this sort of thing but in this
case the genome data exactly
recapitulated the story which was which
was a which was developed by
epidemiologists so this is to illustrate
that that this that this type of thing
could become could become an asset or
maybe even a replacement for an
epidemiologist working on the ground
doing a lot of laborious manual work
and so this work was all published by
our group along with hundred
collaborators in as a nature letter
that's the first time that portable
genome sequencing had been used for for
surveillance of an epidemic and these
are some of the press stories that were
they were written on the article there's
this is a UK paper called the Guardian
the bird and interest and it and even
Bill Gates picked up on this on this
story he's obviously his his charity is
is very interested his foundation is
very interested in in technology which
can be applied to the developing world
to reduce the burden of disease so this
is the type of thing that the foundation
would be interested in so I'm going to
have to increase in speed because I've
only talked about a bonus so far and
I've still got quite a lot to talk about
in Zika so we had a grant that was
funded by the Medical Research Council
as a rapid-response grant to use what we
learned about about doing mobile genome
sequencing and for tackling Ebola for
doing Z currents the both of both of
these viruses are made headlines and
they're very worrying outbreaks the
Ebola because it was it's a very very
very high mortality scary scary virus
and equally Zika was was very worrying
to people because of it's linked to
birth defects so the but there's a big
difference in the way that these viruses
travel Ebola is is a zoonotic virus
assumed to be a zoonotic virus and has
passed which means it comes from an
animal
from an animal reservoir and then a
spread person-to-person Zika is a Zika
is a virus which is spread by mosquitoes
so the mosquito bites and someone who's
got the virus and then is able to spread
it to to other to other people so
there's not it's not exactly the same
it's not exactly the same application
but nevertheless genome sequencing can
still be used to understand the this the
the structure of the virus of the
population of viruses that are
circulating that can tell you quite a
lot as I'll come on to in a minute so
the question that we had for for Zika
surveillance sequencing was really was
really what is the what is the burden of
Zika that is circulating in Brazil this
is we was we were any we're any working
in Brazil although although Zika is
obviously right across the Americas and
we wanted to try and sequence a very
large number of genomes in the previous
in the previous project with near bola
we were sequencing in Samba myself were
sample which was quite a laborious
process and what we wanted to try and do
is to multiplex multiple by multiple
samples on one run and by that I mean
prepare a library which contained
multiple samples that were where the
reads were identifiable by a small
molecular barcode so that we could so
that we can increase the throughput of
the of the sequencing lab so we wanted
to do 12 per flow cell sorts around 12
per day if we if we possibly could and
this was the team that we we assembled
it's a a mixture of Brazilian and
British Portuguese American scientists
and we had four teams that we were
working in we actually traveled over a
thousand kilometres from Recife to
Snowbird from receiving Salvador from
natal Ashley to Salvador and in the
picture there you can see Chaplin who
was a Brazilian student who we actually
now have in are working in our lab at
this very moment she's come over to a
project and she's working on
improvements to to our zika sequencing
protocol but we did this journey by bus
and we stopped in the public the central
public health labs of the federal states
of all of these all of these all of
these places and when we got there we
pulled out the metadata of the samples
and we attempted to sequence them you
can see doing RNA extraction PCR
amplification genome sequencing going on
in the lab in addition to that we've had
a team of entomologist that were looking
at the capturing mosquito so they can
understand the burden of each individual
species in each location and see if we
could correlate that with either the
either the number of Zika positives that
we found or the genomes and this is
their speciation the mosquitoes under a
microscope there and this is a
combination showing where the zebra bus
went there along the north east coast
line and in each place it in each place
we screened hundreds of samples which we
which we were which were given by the
public health labs and in each the there
was on average about ten percent that
were positive for Zika so it's so there
was quite a traditional process because
we still had to extract organize and
test every sample even though we only
got one in ten that was to physique a--
and then in addition the group went out
collecting mosquitoes and they found
multiple species of mosquito in each
place so these ones are the I think the
bee I think this photo is the 80s a
gypsy I which is the species which
actually carry Zika and that was the one
that we were that we were particularly
interested in and you can see from this
heat map here that we had the highest we
collected the highest number a GTI in in
the receive a and maceió States and from
testing the the the samples we had a
number of positives the largest number
of positives was from the Recife he also
had we also had not others from natal
charts Arimathea in Salvador so this is
the this is the number of saga we made
55 we attempted sequencing 55 samples in
a week a or five runs and we ran in some
severe technical difficulties and that
is because the abundance of Zika virus
in in human blood is incredibly small
numbers of viruses so this is a plot
showing the softly this is a keep this
is a real-time PCR and there's something
called their cycle threshold value which
tells you the number of them which tells
they which is a it's prop is the proxy
value for the number of starting to
molecules he had in your sample and for
the case of Zika it was 36 was the most
common value for the samples we did that
we tested so that tells you that there
was a very small number of starting
molecules in the in the in the sample
and that was making the genome
sequencing very difficult we were only
able to
properly sequence these eight samples if
you if you if you define properly as
being more than 50% really we would like
to have been sequencing the entire
genome say we had a we had some some
some real problems at that we weren't
the only ones this is another Greek
Christian Andersen's group at Scripps
and San Diego they were also seeing
similar problems so we ended up
designing a website which I wrote called
primal scheme and the and we had the
interface was made by Andrew Smith and
this basically is a piece of software
for designing primers for for a virus
for a viral genome which where the
primers can be used in multiplex so the
Primus can be included many many
reactions in the same individual tube
and the way that we that we that we did
this was by choosing very high and very
tightly controlled binding temperatures
for the primers and that meant that were
able to amplify the entire genome using
only two two reactions and once we once
we implemented this new method we were
we were really away and this is an
example of some data from Christine
Hansen's lab which I just mentioned
where they tested this new method and
and basically we were seeing pretty well
the whole genome in being able to be
sequence from these two reactions so and
these were these and these episodes so
we went back to Brazil and had had
another attempt and this time as you can
see from the table at the bottom we were
able to achieve genome coverages in the
90s for a number of these samples so we
had eventually we were able to generate
the data that we needed despite the you
know technical challenges that are
associated with Zika
and this gave the the phylogenetic cysts
plenty to work with and they they they
produced this tree here showing that
they'd been and that there was multiple
introductions of Zeek of of Zika in
Brazil that the multiple plates were
currently circulating you can see a
plate associated with Southeast Brazil
Northeast Brazil another one of
Northeast Brazil so very diverse viruses
viruses are able to be detected and what
we were trying to do is they were trying
to use this data to calculate what the
likely introduction date in to Brazil
was and if you if you use some some
advanced modeling methods they were able
to calculate that the likely
introduction likely introduction dates
for these different regions South
America Central America and Caribbean
were words shown on these plots here and
this tells you that Zika have been
circulating unknown or that cryptically
as they call it for a very long time
before the before the national health
authorities realized what's what a big
problem they had and that really tells
he one of this or key important is that
back and illustrate really one of the
key elements of genome surveillance is
really knowing what you've got a lot a
lot sooner and it could happen it could
have potentially been controlled if if
there wasn't if it was known about
earlier problem was that the symptoms
were quite similar to some other viruses
which were endemic in in the country
like dengue and chikungunya so it was it
was flying under the radar for a period
of time
say in conclusion I've tried to cover as
as as best I can some of the key
elements of what we went with the
development that we had to do to be able
to bring a mobile sequencing lab both to
West Africa and Brazil and I've talked
about some of the technical challenges
which which we had to overcome in order
to do that specifically for Ezekial
which is a challenging thing to sequence
but the hope that you I hope that you'll
take away some of the some of the
importance of genome surveillance and
what it can do because we are becoming
an ever more dense densely populated
globe and we're not with with evermore
air travel so these are sort of
conditions which are perfect for the the
spread of viruses and we need more tools
in our Arsenal so that we can we can
control these things when they when they
arise so thanks very much for listening
and I'll take any questions now
sure we will now start the live queuing
we will now start the live Q&A portion
of the webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
type in the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appear on the screen and click on the
send button we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for so let's
start with our first audience number of
questions what future developments do
you anticipate for mobile labs so say so
we are attempting to develop and improve
the current methods that we have we are
working on all elements of the the
technology really and we've we've just
been funded for a further five years to
further develop the lab one of the key
things that we're trying to do is to
improve the speed at which it takes to
bridge to go from sample to answer so
that really that really involves taking
a sample a clinical sample and I'm doing
making it safe so we need to to find
ways of isolating RNA or DNA from a
sample in a safe environment which means
in activating the virus it means that
you have to do it in an environment
which it's safe for the for the actual
operator who's actually doing the
extraction so we use flexible film
Isolators things like something like
that that we that we can do we can
manipulate and handle samples in in a
safe environment that can also be
transported because these things are
normally fixed and very large sorts of
special specialized labs so once we've
got the RNA we're then working on or DNA
we're then working on ways that can we
can improve the speed at which we can go
from
a sample - a sequencing sickness a
sequencing library at the moment that
includes using PCR to amplify a very
small number of molecules that's in the
sample that - it - to a larger number so
that they can be used for this they can
be used for sequencing but these are
still fairly typical
molecular biology steps with enzymatic
reactions and clean ups and more
enzymatic reactions so we're trying to
streamline that whole process maybe even
automate it onto portable microfluidic
devices and we we think we can get this
down to a sort a sort of our at the
moment takes definitely takes a whole
day with we're hoping that we can get
this down to sort of one or two hours
for for sample to answer so certainly
the speed is one thing and I think the
cost the more samples that you can run
at once the effective cost goes down per
sample and it's in order to you to
develop something which is going to be
widely used it needs to be cost
effective and especially if we're going
to be using it in in the developing
world where the cost of these things is
extremely important the men are in
itself is a is a big step forward in
that in that in that respect because the
device itself has a very low value and
you're only paying for the consumables
as opposed to you were having to pay for
the instrument as well you know really
captivating audience today and you have
a captivating audience today and our
next question and you have time for one
more it's really interesting if there
was an outbreak of an unknown virus
tomorrow what would you do
a lot of the a lot of the a lot of what
I've been talking about today is it's
really revolves around surveillance and
that sort of implies that you know that
something is there if and you're really
keeping an eye on it if the if you if
there was an if there was an outbreak of
an unknown virus you know we we would
have to use some different methods in
order to try and define what that might
identify what that virus was as quickly
as possible now you can still use DNA
sequencing technology for that but it
needs to be different you'd have to do a
different method
you can't use PCR the way that we that
we have to amplify the virus genome if
you don't know what the virus genome is
to start with so there's a an
application area called meta genomics
which basically means all of the gene
all of the genomes in in a particular
sample all the nucleic acid in a
particular sample and what we would do
is is take all the RNA or DNA in a
sample and sequence it on mass and try
to identify what we thought using
databases of nabokov existing name
viruses what was what was in that sample
and then if we could if we could
identify what it was in that way we
could then switch to the surveillance
mode where we could design some somesome
an assay which was specific for that
virus and it would switch back to this
surveillance mode like we'll like we've
just been talking about but certainly we
would we would expect to be able to do
these things rapidly and we we have the
equipment and the facilities ready to
deploy this
Thank You Josh for that informative
presentation and thank you for your
important research we just want to also
think lab roots and we also want to
thank our sponsor Oxford nanopore
technologies for making today's
educational webcasts possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December 2017
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thanks for joining us
and we hope to see you again soon
bye-bye